ти не стоїш з вами лізу вимога на
сцене цки знак на метод артур і на сході
україни допо, бо при такій у нас ви
представили місце international the
human rights watch
він і зібралася свічення жертв насильства їхнього
них родичів свитки в таїнства інформацію
правозахисники дишили ви знову купу і
проросійські сепаратисти та українські
скронь та
ранку та каламуті цивільних на законному а під
і куди секретно топи дають артуром у
кімнаті була душа запорошеної теми але і я
була так спк сама фляга ти отримаєш 2
рима хватають шаків струм по відео у мене
була кілька у відкритих ран диких суші
всіх днів а лагуни
його кликав і домени лікаря камера була
приблизно висимо навіси метрів з градом і
на повіках і пластиковим листом щоб не
Чон им кути батчати на вулиці біля камрі
плоди надбудований крок людей кулемін і
привезли на ходу вали на зустрічі на
день 2 ложки каші так гарчить на скрипках
або з чаєм по суботу hе тижнях нас не
до ніг у нас був лише а чай
правозахисники зафіксували 18 випадків
у незаконного і притягнуть рима не
цивільних осіп едвард розум як чекає цілий
шайа в архів до нелюда та закладати
українську владу та сепаратистів прибули
дати закрути то по карате вам не їх
загадала і про росію зі старої росії
не суті світі столітті збоку русів травні місяці
сплив на так дзвони лнр і днр
він особлива зона в ти заходь у тому що
торту рецепт артур та незаконно вранці аня
ціна законні відривання c складені
засіки та бійська щастило шини та їх
приладів слід не треба розуміти
поранений цивільний хосеп зад removal та
хаотичну розрізана не сепаратистська у
груп його ним теперішній роби сержа
системно через так дзвони
міністерство дербас пекін каже
правозахисники human rights watch за
їхнім та словам з українського боку
раніше на законі примули цивільних
добровольці батальйоном тепер і йому
вірна datecs причетник противники з блум
такі як би не закону 3 мати
підозрюваних у офіційних
ізоляторах хату
засіках у харкові нам на даний момент
у нас зараз адже квітки у відома
протягну при найму і на початок васнєцова
руку на території харківського з був
йому повернуть рима
вася 16 sep 15 людині в важко жінка
незаконна краплі води nike на віджет нам
бюджету на моєму житті каштани ви справами
ефективно ті люди не були б навісними
правозахисники запам'ятовують інформацію
перевіряв з різьблених джерел свічення по
чи ревниво я намалював їм amnesty
international the human rights watch та
за кликають офіційний київ
провести розслідування mci та в Україні
секретні в'язниці